premier
ter rien
invité ce soir virgules
cécile le et bernard
pivot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant j'accueille mon cdd il est
toujours en cdd cet homme là
[Musique]
savatier super alors cécile et bernard
thibault est ce que j'ai le droit de
dire que vous êtes père et fils ou fille
et père vont vous dis pas ce que je sais
s'il vous est auteur et journaliste
walaa parce que des fois ya des crétins
qui peuvent uniquement présenté les gens
comme la fille de bernard pivot et ça je
me refuse personnellement ceux qui font
ça je trouve que c'est des connards
voilà qu'ils voient à bernard pivot qui
incarne la culture la langue française
l'orthographe l'intelligence en gros si
un jour vous faites rendez vous en terre
inconnue on vous enverra sur nrj 12 et
puis surtout les dictées qu'on marque
est édité bernard friot c'était mythique
c'est quoi bernard g ou faire faire une
dictée semana
enfin petit stylo tout le monde va jouer
il ya pas si vous voulez pas jouer alors
il faut
bouder j'ai clairement l'arabe
alors allez 1 c'est une télé souvenir
alors bernard vous êtes prêt ou pas oui
vas-y je soussigné bernard pivot déclare
sur l'honneur les diatomées bientôt
m'vila et cela dit et que laëtitia fait
à à johnny alors
[Applaudissements]
adam l'adducteur d'un texte classique
demi siècle c'est que des lumières basse
consommation voici un texte du rappeur
nice qu'à tirer de son pamphlet réseau
vous êtes prêts oui
poser osé poser virgule
suisse où jack dans mon benneteau
n'ont posé suisse où jack dans mon
benneteau mais c'est quoi demande blues
band au fond ne connaissait on n'avait
pas de vocabulaire bernard ça c'est le
domaine d'ô
je suis si jack dans mon bureau mon band
la ligne toulouse quoi où loulou poule
ou toulouse voilà c'est bon pas pu la
voix lasse pas mal ou hulu bululu
ensuite je fais repérage de fans sur les
réseaux de repérage je fais j'ai fait
repérage de femmes sur les jeunes et
réseaux poulou punua la ligne pas
monsieur oui vous pouvez mettre à l'abri
mais sur le physique j'essaie de couper
07 mail est
vivant j'ai vu c'est naulleau toulouse
ou non on remet pour loulou la houle ou
tout à fait
j'ai vu c'est lolo mais si on fait des
fautes parce que ça c'est du côté du
maire n'en sait toujours ouverte une
langue c'est de l'argot cdu c'est du
français c'est de la non non non je vais
pas lui prend ce j'ai vu que c'est le
lot commun pas folle au bac quand je les
faux lohan n'a pas pu le battre quand je
ris fausse défaut l'eau voilà on va
donner doit être clair que
el fellah go qui connaît pas chars aux
attaquants on cherche comme apple ou là
bon on va bernard qui a arrêté
rapidement la non mais essayez traduit
un besoin de comprendre ce que vous avez
à ben c'est très facile donc je suis
sous jack dans mon benneteau ça veut
dire sous alcool voilà partis exactement
jack woods a gagné avec damian à ebondo
et bento bento carte voilà tu prends je
fais repérage de femmes sur les réseaux
c'est un pervers j'ai vu c'est lolo donc
j'ai vu c'est simple elle m'a pas folle
au bac quand je les foule autant dire
que j'ai suivi je les suis my exactement
voilà el fellah go qui connaît pas chars
aux gosses et la toile chars aux
charreaux ci de là
[Applaudissements]
je sens qu'il va pas le succès vert et
télévision pour la rentrée et qui peut
vous succédez à
l'essai
céline à mons et
bénéficie là
correction
alors
le premier élève de la classe tirer
d'après vous c'est moi non c'est pas
vous allez regarder un atout pour
laurent laurent neuf et demi sur 10
voilà vous dis je sais écrire bululu
bien des coeurs pour lolo le deuxième
c'est rosine bravo et ouais
allez un petit point sur hbo et sharon à
8 soit 10 le troisième c'est vous tiriez
pose est posée grisé et l'autre à vous
aviez compris fans sûrement et c'était
femmes d'accord et la troisième c'était
charroux ya pas de w
quatrième de la classe c bouder
[Applaudissements]
piétons vélos
alors bout de la 5 sur 10 on va pas
rentrer dans les détails parce que je
suis sympa ivan a été en plus dispensés
cécile vous êtes
5e avec 4 sur 10 voilà alors est-ce que
vous avez oublié une phrase cécile vous
n'avez pas écrit la phrase elle fait
lago qui connaît pas charron quelle
bande d'escrocs les pivots meliet les
littéraires de mes couilles
j'ai fait un concours entre jean
d'ormesson et jamel c'est jamel qui
avait gagné 28 mai il a fait de droite à
gauche
alors là j'ai peur du résultat je crois
que malheureusement le dernier de la
classe c'est bernard parce qu'il a pas
il n'a pas la
seule phrase en français c'est ce que
j'ai écrit j'ai mis trois sur dix parce
que je suis sympathique mais on va quand
même mieux raser les sorciers
séparer oui
évidemment
correction de ne rien rater le in a
l'habitude abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu